en otros vídeos ya hemos hablado con
detenimiento sobre el producto interno
bruto pib que es una medida de los
bienes y servicios finales que se
producen en un país durante un año
ahora vamos a examinar qué tan buena
medida es el pib y en particular algunas
cosas que no mide en general cuál es el
motivo para querer conocer el total de
bienes y servicios que se producen en un
país bueno podemos verlo como una señal
de actividad económica vamos a escribir
la actividad económica también podemos
verlo como el tamaño o influencia de una
economía tamaño o influencia de la
economía además si tomamos el pib y lo
dividimos entre el número de habitantes
de un país podemos obtener el pib per
cápita que en realidad es el pib por
persona y este podría parecer un
indicador de bienestar que parte de la
idea de que si se producen más bienes y
servicios por persona en un país la
gente de ese país va a estar mejor
y ya que tocamos el tema que es lo que
no mide el pib
bueno pues una de las cosas que no mide
el pib son los bienes no comercializados
a qué nos referimos con esto supongamos
que tengo que ir al aeropuerto
voy a dibujar un aeropuerto esta es la
terminal y aquí tenemos un avión
necesito ir de mi casa al aeropuerto
si llamo a un taxi un über un leaf o
cualquier otro de estos servicios para
que me lleve al aeropuerto la tarifa que
me cobre se incluirá en el pib por otra
parte si le pido a mi esposo que me
lleve al aeropuerto eso no se
contabilizará en el pib aunque se haya
prestado exactamente el mismo servicio
alguien me llevó en su coche de mi casa
al aeropuerto esto se debe a que mi
esposo o mi compañero de cuarto o mi
mejor amigo me prestaron un servicio no
comercializado no estaban intentando
vender el servicio simplemente lo
hicieron como un favor pero fue un
servicio que se me proporcionó y que no
se incluye en el pib un ejemplo del que
a menudo se habla es el cuidado infantil
voy a dibujar un bebé rápidamente si
contratas una niñera para que cuide a tu
bebé eso deberá incluirse en el pib sin
embargo si tú mismo cuidas a tu bebé eso
no se incluirá en el pib porque una vez
más el hecho de que tú cuidas a tu
propio bebé es un servicio no
comercializado
otra cosa que el tip no incluye es la
actividad económica ilegal o podríamos
decir la actividad económica informal
alguna de la cual no es ilegal por
ejemplo si alguien le paga a una niñera
pero no lo registra en sus impuestos eso
no se refleja en las cifras del pib no
es una actividad económica ilegal pero
debería haberse registrado ante la
oficina de impuestos sobre la renta y
entonces se habría contabilizado como
parte del pib pero en este caso no se
incluirá también por supuesto está el
mercado negro una actividad ilegal que
con toda certeza no se incluye en el pib
si alguien vendiera ilegalmente fuegos
artificiales supongamos que están
prohibidos en el estado donde vives
evidentemente no se lo va a informar a
el gobierno entonces ese bien o servicio
no se verá reflejado en el pib y podrás
pensar bueno siempre hay algunas cosas
que se pasan por alto pero sin duda es
bueno que el pib crezca sobre todo que
el pib per cápita crezca en general
puede que tengas razón tal vez es algo
bueno pero también hay otras cosas que
el pib no puede capturar
ni siquiera aunque pudiéramos medir los
bienes y servicios no comercializados y
la actividad económica informal o ilegal
el pib no captura cosas como por ejemplo
la contaminación puede haber un país
cuyo pib esté creciendo muy rápido pero
en el proceso se está contaminando
demasiado y tal vez eso haga que la
calidad de vida disminuye en
determinadas zonas la salud es otro
problema en general los países con un
pib per cápita alto normalmente tienen
buena atención médica principalmente
porque cuentan con más recursos para
ello pero como es la tendencia de salud
en un país y aquí incluso podemos pensar
en cosas como el estrés o sentimientos
de la comunidad por ejemplo una
comunidad de apoyo estas son cosas que
afectan el bienestar de cualquier ser
humano pero el pib no las captura ahora
bien para entender las distintas maneras
en que se clasifican los países en un
intento por captar el índice de
bienestar
podemos ver primero su clasificación por
pib
esta es la clasificación hecha por el
banco mundial en el 2016
puedes ver que eeuu está a la cabeza con
casi 18 puntos 6 billones de dólares de
pib medidos por el banco mundial si
deseas ver una clasificación por
individuo porque piensas esto no te dice
cuánta gente hay ahí y lo que importa es
la productividad dividida entre el
número de personas si realmente quieres
medir el bienestar por persona entonces
puedes consultar algo como esto en pib
percápita observa que aquí eeuu sigue
estando muy arriba pero está bastante
lejos de luxemburgo la razón por la que
luxemburgo no aparece la otra lista es
porque es un país muy pequeño y su
población es muy reducida en comparación
con la de eeuu lo mismo ocurre con suiza
y macao otra cosa que hay que comprender
es que el pib percápita sólo toma el pib
nominal y lo divide entre el número de
personas que hay en un país pero no
miden indica cosas como la desigualdad
de la riqueza no es que cada persona en
luxemburgo obtenga exactamente ciento
mil dólares en bienes y servicios según
el país puede haber más gente de clase
media o menos puede haber más
desigualdad de la riqueza o menos y esto
tampoco es capturado por el pib de igual
modo el pib per cápita no nos dice
realmente cuánto podemos comprar con ese
pib per cápita es por eso que los
expertos analizan cosas como la paridad
del poder adquisitivo que es un pib per
cápita ajustado a cuánto podrías comprar
con estos recursos medidos en dólares
estadounidenses y en la clasificación
del pib per cápita a paridad del poder
adquisitivo podemos ver que qatar se
encuentra a la cabeza qatar estaba
bastante arriba pero supongo que puedes
comprar y obtener más bienes y servicios
con ese pib nominal per cápita medido en
dólares estadounidenses en qatar que en
eeuu
vamos a terminar aquí no existe una
medida absolutamente perfecta de la
actividad económica tampoco del
bienestar pero el pib es la mejor que
tenemos intenta pensar en otras por
ejemplo la onu ha intentado medir la
felicidad
tiene esta clasificación de los países
de acuerdo a la felicidad y también
tiene un informe mundial anual de la
felicidad no voy a entrar en detalles
pero más allá del pib también toma en
cuenta cosas como la salud y otras
medidas de bienestar como puedes ver los
países que encabezan esta lista tienden
a tener un pib bastante elevado pero
esta clasificación no es la misma que
vimos en el pib percápita a paridad de
poder adquisitivo sin duda todo esto son
cosas muy interesantes en que pensar nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo